Luke Tom and Nathan here with the
outdoor boys YouTube channel today we're
metal detecting
[Music]
all right me and the boys we're here and
Clifton Virginia and we are gonna do
some metal detecting isn't that right
tom yeah you ready
hey Nathan you ready - all right let's
do it so I don't think I've ever taken
the boys metal detecting before I used
to do it a ton back in the days that was
kind of my go-to hobby for a year or two
but considering how many fishing videos
have been doing I just haven't had time
so we're gonna give it a go and we're
just go to a little playground here
because I think the kids will enjoy that
all right guys come on hurry up over by
the playground equipment all right see
check out this playground we got here
this is a nice one cuz it's an old
playground it's not a new one and it's
got wood chips and really easy for
little kids to dig in the wood chips so
this makes it easy for the boys to help
out hey you guys want to do this here
well you need a shovel
Nathan you need a shovel you K you got
your shovel okay so check this out this
is my white prism for it's about ten
years old but it still works tells me
the the depth and I can tells me a
little bit about what is actually over
there so it's got a pretty good
discrimination but check this out yeah
you wanna see you you guys can play
buddy
Tom you like that this you're making a
castle yeah something down here but
whether it's something cool or not I
don't know you see it uh-huh
here it is see ya
[Applause]
there you go a penny money we found some
treasure that's right here guys
it's right here right there no Nathan
dig right here some oh I think I see it
or is that a worm no it was a worm it's
here yeah let's see it lets see what
date it is since 1982 from an ancient
period in American history
[Music]
yes in here yeah 1999 another century
it's artifacts from another century no
yes it right there but there's tons of
them around I think what I bought this
thing about twelve years ago it was cost
about 400 bucks and the pinpointer was
about $100 you can get metal detectors
they're like $20 and they all detect
metal about the same the difference is
when you buy the fancy ones they do
better at discrimination I'm telling you
exactly what it is how deep it is
pinpointing it and sorting out junk and
good stuff
so if you don't want to be digging up
tin foil and pop tops and bottle caps
all the time you get a nicer metal
detector it can tell you what's in the
ground and you can figure out what's
worth digging for and what's not a cheap
one will just buzz all the time for
anything metal whether it's a nail or a
gold ring it doesn't it can't really
tell the difference
oh it's fine stuck at the bottom of
slides yeah you did there is
it's a 2014 penny yeah I hit the new one
those are the best even after you find
something check the hole because often
where you find one penny you'll find
other stuff you usually won't find
expensive treasure or amazing artifacts
and digging in a playground but if you
want to learn how to use your metal
detector it's a great place to start
it's super easy to dig in the wood chips
and there's almost always something to
find coins little cheap jewelry keys
toys and a lot of junk - so you kind of
figure out what you need to dig forward
and learn how to use your machine and
it's a nice place to learn and the kids
enjoy it - all right that's something
big here Tommy
Tommy go dig right there you just popped
out Quinn this toy boy with this it's
right here it's pretty shallow - you
guys aren't you guys go dig around right
there right around here you guys dig dig
right here you got it okay grab it
that's not a penny it's a clue - coin
yeah it's a it's a nickel there you go
you want me to push you
okay hold still Oh dime now we're
rolling in the big books dig right there
see right there dig right there no it's
not you see it it's a big coin yeah here
let's hold it up show what it is yeah
it's a quarter let's see if we can find
another one there might be more okay
hear that see there's something else
here yeah I did get in your face
carefully well look at that look at the
look at this
that's a cicada see ya there
- cicada baby
Oh grab it he's here
see right there yeah said it let's see
is it no it's metal I think it's a ball
of tinfoil or something hey guys it's
you got a dig down on deep cause it's
right in here
this it looks like a bit of iron so
wherever to clean that up to figure out
what that is a little bit of steel will
iron a bit of slag iron portraits right
right there dig around it's really close
to the surface that's a shiny one yeah
yeah there you go nice shiny quarter I'm
pushing you for a little bit okay see
that's a recent drop well that right
there is the mother lode Tom 50 cents
man there's an earring Tom there's an
earring
[ __ ] yeah that's an Iroquois there you
go it's a pocketknife that nice yeah see
that can't tell if it's rusty or just
dirty and I don't think it's that rusty
I think it's just got caked in clay I'll
go and clean it up to see if we can get
it open all right little Barlow
pocketknife yeah put that in my pocket
yeah that was actually pretty calm and
it said it said it was 2 inches down and
it was actually a pull-tab
or a coin it was actually four inches
down it's the machine has a hard time
telling the difference between something
that is small and close and something
that's big and far away oh hey guys we
got a coin hey hold on Nathan hurt his
finger
let me see your finger let me see
it was finger right there how's your
finger feel your finger feel better Oh
what you doing what are you showing dad
[Music]
oh you what that is no that's a Boy
Scout
Oh neck handkerchief that's it's a Cub
Scout neck handkerchief that's for
somebody who achieves the rank of wolf
it's got a little wolf on it sake order
any medal in here let me see smile oh
you fell down hit your teeth hit your
face
yeah oh it's a penny from an ancient
time 1981 back when big hair and and
shoulder pads and hey your pants are not
coming undone oh right here is right in
here somewhere
oh ho there it is alright here's our
haul from about an hour of metal
detecting we got a dollar 25 in quarters
a dime a nickel
five pennies plus one that Tommy lost
this cool pocket knife which I actually
think I can clean up I'm not sure how
much damage is done but it looks like
it's still in pretty good shape
found this Boy Scout Wolfe neckerchief a
little little earring post some random
pieces of metal which I need to clean up
I have no idea what those are another
glob of metal and this weird thing yeah
so and we found a perfectly good toy car
yeah absolutely you go play with the toy
car that's yours bud
[Music]
in nathan is your finger better it hurts
I'm sorry but what would you like to go
get some ice cream or something alright
come on guys
let's go see if Peterson's is open we go
vanilla for Tommy cotton candy for
Nathan and chocolate for daddy well
thanks for watching we hope you guys
enjoyed this video from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel if you'd like to see
more videos from our YouTube channel
click Subscribe we put out new videos
every week thanks for watching
[Music]